[Music]
hello how are you greetings jaramillo comes out
with his brief informative for today Tuesday
June 15 today marks the ninth
anniversary of the daca program which
grants a social security number and
temporary legal status to thousands of
young people brought here as children  in las
vegas they will offer a workshop today
for first time applicants at
4 pm inside the
rafael rivera community center located near mon javi
and sur the requirements for this benefit
include not having a criminal record having
arrived in the united states before
2007  having arrived before turning
16 having obtained a high
school diploma indicated having been part of
the military service
also today local leaders together with the
organization my family votes organize
a food distribution in addition to a
vaccination clinic both will be from
three to six of  the afternoon at
globo kaminis high school near
washington and pecos the fighter vaccine
will be distributed to ages 12 and up  the
jensen only available for
adults for more information visit
our page same diagonal dotcom
in Spanish
and on the other hand this excessive heat
can affect your vehicle for this
reason we offer you some advice
make sure that the liquids are
where they drink and do not look empty too
check your battery and make sure your
tires have the proper air to
circulate in the summer if you plan to make
long trips always have bottles of
water within reach and now we move on to
the weather forecast for today we will have
a maximum reaching 113 degrees we will
continue with the heat  excessive
exceeding 110 degrees for the rest
of the week remember not to leave children
or pets inside the vehicle during
these high temperatures nice day I
am sal y jaramillo and this was your brief
informative edition in Spanish
[Music]